You look so beautiful.
Same with you.
I was like, I have to look at the lens
but I really just want to look at you.
So if I do that, that's why
cause you're really beautiful too.
Oh, you're so beautiful.
Inside and out.
I was so excited to have this conversation with you.
And I did a lot of homework for it because
there was so many things I wanted to discuss with you.
And you have this new series, which I saw
I was so scared.
I had to text everyone on the show that I was like
I'm so scared right now, please.
And anyone whilst watching it I'm terrified.
I need, I need people.
"Tell Me Your Secrets."
It's this buzzy new Amazon show.
I mean, it taps into my worst nightmare obviously.
And I think every mother/parent's worst nightmare.
How did you handle the subject matter
and how are you so strong?
Cause it's incredible.
You know, I wasn't that interested in playing
a pure, bad sociopath person.
I always like to know why people do what they do.
And we started from this pretty simple premise
and a pretty universal premise,
which is how far would you go
to find and protect your child?
And you know, I feel like I've said it this
and you hear it all the time.
Like I'm not a violent person
but if anybody came after my kid, you know,
so it's sort of like this culturally sanctioned
reason for going nuts.
And so I started in a pretty place where I can
horribly try to imagine.
And then, and then I just went on this rocket ride.
One of the things with your podcast, "The Challengers"
of which you say that you should look at things
not as roadblocks, but as doorways.
And I was listening
to the podcast that you talked to your amazing husband,
Brad Silberling, who's an incredible director,
and he lost his girlfriend, Rebecca Schaefer
who was an actress
and I thought it was so incredible
that you guys talked about that story.
Yeah, well that, that's sort of a prime example of
you know, this, this devastating thing that happened to him
which is getting the call that nobody wants to get
which is that your loved one has been
shot dead randomly.
And it reverberated throughout LA and throughout the world.
And it was sort of, kind of the first time
that stalker stuff sort of really came to the fore.
I met Brad about five years after that.
And I immediately was drawn to him.
And when I heard that fact about him, I said
you know, I have all these big feelings
but I don't know what to do with
with this idea that he was like
in love with this beautiful young woman who was shot down.
And if she hadn't died,
you know, I was kind of hung up on like,
there's only one for everybody,
and if she hadn't died and I was sloppy seconds
and just I was all, you know, in love, I was vulnerable.
And my father said,
well if it continues, and he continues to love you
in the way that that is good for you
you may come to feel grateful
to her for teaching him how to love.
And that is absolutely what happened.
And so my heart, and you know, now Rebecca is in my heart
in a way that I, you know,
it wasn't like competition.
It wasn't jealousy.
It was like, Oh, all these things that happen to us
prepare us to,
to love and to be more present.
And that is a hundred percent true.
Thank you so much for a, sharing that wisdom
of how we can all learn
because you cannot change someone's history.
So,
you know,
embracing and honoring is really the only approach we have.
But gosh, it takes lifetimes,
it feels like to learn that
in a lot of relationships
and it happened in 1989 in West Hollywood.
And in 1989, I moved out into my first apartment at 14
emancipated by the courts.
And this very much was front and center news.
There was no stories like it
it changed the landscape for everyone.
And I thank you for sharing that
because I was a part of that time
and that culture when Rebecca was unfortunately killed it
it, it, it changed everything for everyone.
Well, I am so enamored with you and
the way that you are living your life, sharing it
and giving us all the nod that looking at it
and talking about it is what brings the light
and gets rid of the darkness.
And thank you for leading the charge on that
with your podcast, 'The Challengers."
And if you want to watch this buzzy, important
cool show that everybody's talking about
and it is riveting!
It is called "Tell Me Your Secrets"
It's on Amazon Prime right now.
And thank you, Amy.
Oh, it's my,
okay, now I'm going to take you in and all your beauty
and your adorableness, and you know what
(beep) that accordion potato like, who needs that
(laughing)
That's just like so much work and you know...
A hundred, thank you.
A hundred percent.
The accordion potato gets a
And thank you so much
Right back at you.
Thank you for being a light in this world.
Thank you, thank you, thank you
(audience clapping & cheering)
(upbeat music)